yellow welcome to a new video this is
just a short-term yeah game fragment of
a blitz game that I played yesterday on
at the German team blitz championships
it's a pretty a pretty nice event
yesterday it's um yeah 28 teams from all
over Germany who qualified to play for
the German team blitz title this are
four players per team and at the end he
had the team of ports one processor on
part of cologne so on but there weren't
any players from Cologne and the steamer
it was a very very strong team which at
the end one all all its matches which is
despite them being very strong very
remarkable they scored he had 27 match
wins but the steam was have cost very
very strong consisting of a Grand
Masters only Wroblewski playing on board
one he's got close to 2,700 please
yellow and then also luke from valley
from the Netherlands who bless keys from
Russia of course on then we got flooded
Slav to cart chef former European
champion also to 650 round rated then
Vladimir Buckland I think from Ukraine
I'm not quite sure also to six something
and the reserve board was Eric running
dual also from the from the Netherlands
like from really and he's also to 580 or
something but mostly they played with
those four guys above to 650 yeah very
strong team and what I'm going to
present mmm it's a fragment of a game of
mine that I had against daniel friedman
is the the current German champion rated
to 653 yellow so I'm a huge outsider but
in blitz yeah some sometimes upsets are
possible and this is the game which has
huge mischance by me right in the
opening and I wanted to show it quickly
because it's um yeah quite quite
interesting to see a how quickly i'm
like could get in trouble here um I
don't want to analyze the game really an
in-depth just just show them the
critical position and so we had some
Queens gambit semi slavia aunty played
this a 6-line which was also tested in
the current world championship or the
recently concluded World Championship
applet b3 safe move then he won't see
five which is which surprised me a bit
because Bishop before is usually played
here but okay this is not so important I
just developed and you just developed
our pieces here so now as an interesting
moment on because white has some choice
here I wasn't quite sure how to put the
pieces but ok in a blitz game you cannot
spend a minute or so so why it could
could easily play move like let's say
I'm rookie one here the idea being if
black decides to to grab the spawn of
course then there's a standard tactic
bishop age 7 and them I'm just winning
the Queen here so the default porn
always was protected due to this
technical trick but I played also quite
quite quickly I played on Queenie too
because I simply thought he cannot take
this pawn I didn't calculate really am
what happens if he does but it just
looks it looks at label but well what
happened you actually grab this porn
after some thought yeah maybe I mean one
thing is black isn't too comfortable yet
still has this somewhat bad bishop which
might be coming to play along these
lines but what is quite comfortable it's
nothing a decisive or anything but um
okay at the end he decided to grab the
porn which actually just lose this but I
didn't I didn't calculate this properly
okay need to take yeah now the important
position here of course the the most
natural move which she would instantly
place 95 and of course I calculated this
move but I simply didn't didn't look far
enough okay um to to tell what I played
actually played 94 at the end but 95 is
the thing here which attacks the queen
of course and the bishop so he needs to
retreat the Queen to c5 there's no no
alternative and then yeah my problem was
here you can can calculate quite some
lines my problem was on the the thing
what I can play is I can take here and
this is this is now somewhat
embarrassing for black if you would take
the night I can just take hint and win I
don't know rook at the end so he cannot
do this so it needs to recapture the
bishop somehow and the issue is if he
takes with the bishop then I have yeah
two ways to win this game actually after
the game he told me Queenie for was what
what he saw and this is pretty much
winning also threatening on age 7 and he
cannot protect this so let's say a
rookie move as check check name is made
yeah so we cannot get an X square for
the king and okay this I can just grab
and I material up even stronger then
Queenie for but ok where the witness the
win this Queen age 5 which threaten
dismayed and also Knight f6 check and I
win the Queen so this is just curtains
immediately
it's not even a piece it's it's more so
you cannot take here but it can take
with a pole and somewhere around here I
think I am I simply calculated not far
enough the problem here is okay the
night is hanging if I if I just capture
let's say here i don't i don't really i
mean even this is good even this is good
let's say here here and what does black
play now this is essentially the idea
that I overlooked in the game that I can
actually get the Queen to h4 threatening
this checkmate on age 7 and he cannot
play this move because well there's
simply a big piece hanging only seven so
just just stupid I mean okay this also
this is winning the same motive what I
simply didn't see this Queen H form I
was always thinking along the lines of
Queen h5 something like like let's say
this here and then he can play this and
it's it's nothing yeah I mean maybe an
attack but it's it's nothing winning
immediately and I simply didn't take
into account that I can go to h4 this
was my program always thought about this
diagonal I never thought about this
sidestepping move and I pretty quickly
then abandoned the idea of 95 and at the
end went playing here which after this
also it's a very strong attack and i
think maybe i was i was still winning
later this is not a winning position
black and maybe defend here but i was
still winning late and but somehow
didn't didn't manage to find it it is
very strong blitz play I mean it's even
stronger blitz then
and a tournament chess sir so this may
be more like 27 in blit so I was glad to
do to get a fight am well and in the end
he obtained a winning position totally
winning but we were very low on time and
at the end blow both Flags fell so it
ended up in a draw but bye-bye yeah time
overstepping the time for both players
at the same time so yeah maybe been
somewhat fair result considering that
here this 95 would have one immediately
yeah it would have been a very very nice
win here but well it's blitz and you
need to calculate properly maybe I also
played this too quickly i'm not sure i
mean it's not really difficult to see
i'm pretty sure if you give me like like
a minute more something i would see it
but have no idea idea this this this is
really that you go to h4 somewhere I was
always thinking queen age 5 and this is
just much better because it has this is
seven point I am alright i just wanted
to show this some quicker fragment hope
you enjoyed it and it shows that yeah
you really need to maybe even in the
Blitz game and will invest a bit bit of
time it at one point because if you
really feel that you're winning or
something then then you should maybe
think thing more I was really thinking
he did not do this and then I somehow I
didn't see something immediately and
then has someone believed ok what you
did there was super risky but maybe it's
still halfway playable and I didn't
follow up this is 95 to the end no all
right yeah thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed it and yeah I talk to you soon
in a new video